تعرف على هؤلاء الشباب الأربعة الذين قرروا
حزم حقائبهم والتوجه إلى
مكان العمل، حيث خططت بريثي بارثاساريتي
للسفر لمدة ستة أشهر فقط عندما
تركت وظيفتها في البنك، وقد استمرت الآن
لمدة خمس سنوات ونصف
كمسافر بدوام كامل هنا  كيف يمكن أن يبدو أي يوم عادي في
حياتي وكأنه أول رحلة لها بعد العمل
كانت إلى الكشمير في
منطقة الهيمالايا في شمال الهند، فقد رأت الثلج
لأول مرة منذ سنوات وحاولت
التزلج منذ أن بدأت بارثوس بالفعل في
الترحال، وشاهدت سريلانكا وجزر المالديف
وأستراليا.  Great Barrier
Reef هي الآن منشئة محتوى للسفر
ولكنها تتوقف حاليًا
في مايو 2021. لقد تركت وظيفتي مع
توفير أكثر من 10 آلاف فقط للسفر نيكول التي
استمتعت بوظيفة المبيعات حتى بدأت
العمل عن بعد أثناء الوباء والتي
ادخرت راتبها  وعندما
بدأت قيود السفر في التخفيف في عام 2021،
قررت ترك وظيفتها وحجزت
تذكرة إلى غواتيمالا، وكان من
المفترض أن تستغرق الرحلة أسبوعين ولكنها استدعت للعمل
التطوعي الصيفي في أوروبا
تليها زيارة لمدة ثلاثة أشهر إلى المكسيك التي
تركز على  على توفير أموالنا
للاستكشاف لأطول فترة ممكنة، تخرج جاك سكوت
من الجامعة
بدرجة في الهندسة الميكانيكية وقضى
تسعة أشهر يعمل في
شركة تبريد، وكان صديقه الجامعي جيمس فليمنج
قد سئم من الجلوس أمام جهاز الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص به أثناء
عمله كموظف مكتبي.
منظم تدريب، لذلك استيقظنا اليوم على هذا
المنظر الرائع للصحراء في عام 2022،
قرر الزوجان القيام
برحلة بطول 17000 ميل من أوركني اسكتلندا،
مسقط رأس سكوت إلى هراري، زيمبابوي،
مسقط رأس فليمينغ في سيارة لاند كروزر
اشتروها على فيسبوك، ووجد
فليمينغ المعدل وظيفة  كان يعمل في مجال
الحفاظ على البيئة في زيمبابوي، وقام سكوت
بتغيير مسيرته المهنية وهو الآن يغوص بحثًا
عن الأسقلوب وأوركني